[Musique]
ceci ramène sur terre deux cosmonautes
russes et un astronaute américain
l'équipage était dans la station
spatiale internationale at il eu des
mouvements dans certaines unités russes
3 1 de kiev depuis un jour ou deux oui
c'est ce que nous pensons un petit
nombre whittington
mais nous pensons qu'il s'agit d'un
repositionnement pas d'un vrai retrait
la grande prudence sur ces annonces ont
habitués à quelques déceptions dans les
semaines passées d'abord je me suis
trompé sur une seule chose vous avez
raison je croyais pas qu'il allait
attaquer mais accordez moi que tous les
spécialistes le penser la même chose je
suis sûr qu'on va vers une explosion
sociale j'en suis sûr parce que là toute
la situation se dégrade se dégrade on a
discuté de la flambée des prix et de
cette inflation qui est devenue
insupportable emmanuel macron avait déjà
l'oreille des chasseurs il peut
désormais compter sur le bulletin de
vote de leur patron willie fresnes dans
le parisien ce matin il s'en explique il
ne m'a pas déçu aucune loi ou
amendements pouvant abîmer la chasse n'a
été adopté dans ce quinquennat gens
pourraient peut-être d'autres termes
dégueulasse jules employés c'est
l'attitude de deluga b je veux dire
qu'il est très froid dans l'agression
mais ce serait n'a droit d'avoir un avis
mais vous savez qui la table ouverte à
l'elysée depuis des années c'est
choquant c'est choquant que les lobbys
et trouver une telle place pendant le
quinquennat macron très attendu
également la prise de parole notamment
du directeur de la prison d'arles ce
matin à l'assemblée nationale claude
aurous duos une chose coup sûr si dieu
existe et duru pas la guerre
excusez moi c'est pas crédible c'est
bien crédible
donc voulait se payer quelqu'un de connu
président des chasseurs se transforme un
peu en rabatteurs de voix là ainsi le
rabatteur de voix pour emmanuel macron
moi je ne sais pas ce qu'en pensent les
chasseurs est ce qu'ils vont apprécier
d'être transformé en gibier électorale
fournée pour exproprier les riches on
est pour exproprier les multinationales
comme total on est pour que l'industrie
pharmaceutique ce soit une industrie ça
veut dire quoi délaissé - réponse s'il
vous plaît je sais comme pas possible de
faire comme ça emmanuel macron 10 800
millions c'est trop cher pour les
handicapés et il donne un milliard en
2021 à des cabinets d'études qui en plus
ont conseillé de files heures avant vous
affolez pas vous n'êtes pas obligé d
éducation a maintenant doublé sépare les
deux trois minutes y'a pas de soucis
donc mckinsey a fait des prestations
gratuites pour l'elysée que mc kinsey
l'a aidé dans sa campagne de 2010 cette
lincoln a même était gérant chez
rothschild où il a organisé une
négociation entre pfizer donc rien ne
saurait interdire à une personne d'aller
voter et donc évidemment pour des
personnes qui seraient contaminés par
l'aco vide dans les jours précédant le
vote elles pourront aller voter
évidemment quand un peuple traîne les
pieds on ne reconnaît plus son système
politique ne reconnaît plus son système
médiatique se réfugie dans la colère
je dis que c'est dangereux jean vincent
placé mise en examen hier soir pour
agressions sexuelles et harcèlement
sexuel l'ancien secrétaire d'état
écologiste a passé 24 heures en garde à
vue est ce qu'il ya un pacte secret
entre emmanuel macron et nicolas sarkozy
est ce que nicolas sarkozy a promis
d'aider la macro ni pour être réélu là
en 2022 emmanuel macron à une seule
constante il change d'avis ton temps sur
tout sauf une un sujet l'europe il est
toujours ils sacrifient toujours les
intérêts de la france sa chimère de des
états unis d'europe est un pacte tacite
un chacun n'a pas écrit alan qu'on le
fait que effectivement il s'entraînerait
mais c'est tellement logique vous le
rappeliez tout à l'heure les
agriculteurs ne sont pas des ennemis
c'est pas eux qui polluent c'est pas eux
qui réchauffe la planète
et au moins ils ne mentent pas comme un
boulet politique
gérald darmanin va finir le boulot dia
cinq ans c'est à dire préparer les
législatives et opérer cette grande
entreprise de débauchage chez des élus
aient l'air pour avoir une majorité
franche en juin prochain